good morning everyone and welcome to
developing flexible authorization
capabilities with asp.net core
I'm Jason Taylor a solution architect
for ssw
I help customers develop deploy and test
custom Solutions in the cloud
you can find me on GitHub at
jasontaylordiff or on my blog
jasontaylor.dev
today I'd like to show you authorization
with asp.net core we'll look at
authorization asp.net core the standard
approach and a flexible approach we'll
look at authorization and Blazer
webassembly and we'll look at some code
three demos and I'll summarize it for
you at the end
before we get started I just want to let
you know that ssw has a cool new ssw
Rewards app you can download this app
from the app store by searching for ssw
you can scan codes at ssw talks and
events to earn points and collect prizes
a little bit of background information
before we get started
so authentication is the process of
determining a user's identity whereas
authorization is the process of
determining what resources a user has
access to
now authentication is independent of
authorization but you need to remember
that authorization requires an
authenticated user
so authorization determines access to
resources but what exactly are resources
well resources can be a number of things
such as data files views and features
authorization also includes defining and
enforcing access control rules as
policies which are then used by the
system to Grant or reject access
requests to specified resources
the focus of this talk will be
authorization with asp.net core
I'll demonstrate a typical approach
using role-based access control and then
a flexible approach using
permissions-based access control and
you'll see that with the flexible
approach for sufficiently complex
problems that this will save you a lot
of time and money improving your
maintainability of your code
and generally the happiness of your
developers
so the talk will be built using sorry
that code will be built using Blazer
webassembly and asp.net core and I'll
share a link to the code and slides at
the end
so authorization with asbnet core
it supports very simple authorization
capabilities such as authentic such as
authorizing an authenticated user or
allowing Anonymous access for a user
but it also includes sophisticated
authorization capabilities such as
role-based claim space policy-based
resource-based and view based
authorization
in addition it's easy to create custom
authorization policies and it's also
easy to customize the authorization
Behavior using middleware
let's take a look at some examples so
first with simple authorization we can
use the authorize attribute on a
controller action or razor page
in this example the authorized attribute
has been applied to the account
controller and that means that users of
the account controller can only access
login and log out if they're
authenticated
which of course is a big problem because
they they can't log in unless they're
authorized
we can fix that we'll move the
authorizer tribute down to logout so now
Anonymous users can access login and
authenticated users can access logout
here's another example where we've again
applied authorized to the account
controller and we've simply applied
allow Anonymous to the login so that
means all of the actions within this
controller will require authenticated
user except for the login action
now let's look at authorization with
roles again using the authorized
attribute we can specify roles for a
particular action so in this case we've
applied the authorized attribute to the
administrator controller and specified
the administrator's role that means to
access the actions within this
controller it requires an authenticated
user who is a member of the
administrator's role
next up we have the authorized attribute
specifying two roles that means the user
must be a member of either the
administrator's role or the accounts
role
and finally we have two authorized
attributes both specifying individual
roles and this means that the user must
be a member of both the administrators
and the accounts roles so you can see
the authorized attribute is quite
flexible you can apply it in a variety
of different ways to divide to Define
your access policy
next up we have authorization with
policies which is really the engine of
the ASP net core authorization system
with policy-based authorization we can
again use the authorizer tribute to
specify a policy in this case access to
the employee controller will be strictly
restricted to users who meet the
requirements of the employees only
policy how do we Define that well
generally these policies are defined
when you're defining your services so
we've added a policy called employees
only and added a single requirement and
that is that this the authenticated user
requires a claim employee number but we
don't much need to worry about what
value it is just that they have that
claim
now we'll look at authorization in
Blazer webassembly it's important to
remember that Blazer webassembly is an
asp.net core technology so it supports
many of the same authorization
capabilities
so it supports simple authorization
capabilities such as allowing Anonymous
access or restricting on access to
certain capabilities
it includes the same sophisticated
authorization capabilities such as role
claims and policy based and it includes
additional authorization components such
as authorized View and authorized route
View
the important thing about Blazer
webassembly is that it's running in the
client so it's important to remember
that the authorization you place there
like the validation that you place there
is really only to improve the UI and
user experience we can conditionally
show and hide items but all of that can
be bypassed by the user by disabling
JavaScript or crafting an attack so we
still need to enforce authorization on
the server side
let's have a look at some examples with
blazer so for simple authorization again
we can use the authorized attribute on a
routable page so in this case we've
simply applied the tribute which means
that only authenticated users can access
the home page
here the authorized attribute has
specified two roles so an authenticated
user who is either a member of
Administrators or the accounts role
and here we've specified the employees
only policy so only a authenticated user
who meets the requirements of the
employees only policy can access the
users page
authorization with views so we apply
authorization sorry the authorized view
to selectively display content
three examples here you can see the home
link is only accessible to authenticated
users the counter link is only
accessible to authenticated users who
are a member of one of those roles and
finally the users link is only
accessible to the employees
next up we have the authorized view
where we're specifying what to show if
the user is not authorized so you can
see here the login link will be
displayed if the user is not authorized
let's have a look at what it takes using
the typical approach with ASP net core
authorization being role-based
authorization let's have a look at what
it takes to add a new role to an
existing application and in this in this
scenario we're going to add an auditor
role to support certain requirements
let's have a look at the application
quickly so this is the application it's
Blazer webassembly hosted on asp.net
core at the moment I've built in some
capabilities to manage the users you can
see there's an admin and an auditor user
and in this form we can actually assign
different roles so we're going to go
ahead and create an Auditor's role for
the auditor
for a little bit of fun we can also see
the claims that are associated with the
user in this case I'm logged in as the
administrator and I can see the
administrator sorry the role claim which
has a single value of Administrators
so to add a new role we'll go to the
database initializer that's where I've
defined the roles for this application
so we'll duplicate this code I love to
copy and paste and uh
I love multi-cursor too
so we specify the auditor's role and
then here using asp.net core identity
we'll go ahead and create the Auditors
role
again copying and pasting
and
foreigners there we go so when the
application starts up in development it
will automatically create that Auditor's
role for me and I can assign the auditor
to that role
just minimize that
but that's not the only change we need
to make because we're not actually using
the auditor's role anywhere so let's
start at the front end and apply the
auditor's role where necessary the first
thing that I'd like to update is the nav
menu
not that one
nav menu
there we go
so in the nav menu I'd like to give the
auditor access to let's see
to see the counter so we put in the
auditor's role there
uh to be able to see the weather
forecast
so we'll put in the Auditors role there
and also to see a list of users that'll
give them a little bit more access than
what I want but I don't have actually
fine-grained control of authorization on
users so they'll be able to see the
users but they'll also be able to edit
the users so that's a bit problematic
but that's okay we'll stick with that so
that's the nav menu if I was to run it
now they could see the nav menu but they
wouldn't be able to access any of the
pages because they're all secured as
well so let's have a look at the counter
page
and we can see that's administrators and
accounts we can go ahead and add
auditors
fetch data
okay same thing
and the users page
that's in users index
all right
now that takes care of the front end but
we have controllers in the back end
which also require authorization so
we're protecting the resources on the
back end of course so we can start with
the weather forecast controller which
Powers the fetch data
and we can also update the user's
controller
and I think that's it
so let's run the application again and
see how it works
so so far we've had to make a bunch of
code changes we'll need to eventually
test this application deploy it and
we'll also need to document these
authorization requirements at the moment
these requirements are only declared in
code so we'll need a separate piece of
documentation that we can share with the
business so they can understand who has
access to what and of course we're going
to need to keep that document up to date
which as developers something we're very
good at
all right
over here
let's see if we can see that new
Auditors roll and assign the auditor
we can that's a good start
just need to click on it
there we go
save that
and then I'll go ahead and log out
and log back in as an auditor
here we go
so that's good I can see counter fetch
data and users
I can access counter I can access fetch
data and I can also access the data
coming back from the server
I can access users unfortunately I have
a little bit more access than what I
need because I don't have fine grown
grain control of that access
so we need something a little bit more
than that
all right so what would it look like if
we had a better system what would it
look like if we had flexible
authorization with asp.net core
well first I'd like it to be easy for me
to add new roles and configure Access
Control
following that I'd like it to be easy to
reconfigure access control for existing
roles for large organizations and large
applications these things change all the
time I was in a one Organization for
eight years and they went through three
restructures with different team names
my role didn't change but my team name
did and that affected a lot of the
systems
I would like to be able to remove roles
without impacting existing Access
Control checks we can't do that right
now if we want to go and remove roles
we've got code changes testing building
deploying and documentation updates
I would like to easily view Access
Control policies I really don't want to
maintain any documentation on that
and I'd like to support all of the above
as standard application features I want
this to be the experience that's
provided to the end users of the
application
so let's have a look at this adding a
new role again the same Auditor's role
but this time using a flexible approach
to authorization
so we'll close down basic auth
and load up flexible loss
a little bit of a preview there of the
permissions
but we'll run the application first
you get in there
this is my new super fast laptop
always a little bit slower on stage
okay let's log in
I'll log in again as administrator
and here we have a couple of new
features we've got roles so let's go in
and create an Auditor's role
that's done now let's go and Define
access control for the auditor's role
so here it is and here are all the
permissions that are available in the
system you can see that these
permissions are a lot more fine-grained
a lot more associated with the actual
functionality in the application
for the auditor I really just want them
to be able to access the counter the
forecast and to view the users not to be
able to manage the users so I think
we'll just leave it at that
now those changes are already saved so
we can go ahead and log out and log back
in as the auditor oh actually I forgot
to assign the auditor roll to the
auditor so I have to do that first
ah
okay so we'll go to users
and assign that role
so you can assign one or more roles to
users and of course the user is going to
inherit the permissions that have been
assigned to those roles
all right so back out
and in as the auditor
okay this is looking good we have access
to counter we have access to fetch data
we have access to view the users not to
edit the users and we can also see
claims which is nice you can see the
auditor's role has been added as a claim
we also have this new permissions claim
which is has an interesting value of
100. we'll get to that soon first I'd
like to compare the standard approach
with the flexible approach
so with the standard approach we had to
make code changes we had to test those
changes which we didn't do we had to
build and deploy and we had to document
those changes which we also didn't do
there's probably going to be some bug
fixes on the way because we're actually
impacting quite a few components within
the system
with the flexible approach we actually
weren't required so we just had free
time that could have been completed by
an administrator or an end user and
that's excellent we don't have to focus
on these basic concerns means we can
start delivering new requirements we can
start delivering business value
I'd like to talk about how the flexible
approach works first let's think about
the permissions
so permissions define granular access to
resources we saw that when we were able
to provide fine-grained control of the
user's feature we could either view
users or edit users of course both
it was easy for developers to create
permissions and we'll have a
demonstration of that later and
permissions are created generally when
you're creating a new feature so we
don't have to go in and manage
authorization independently it's only
when we're creating a new feature or if
the access policy changes it's a very
normal development flow permissions are
not assigned directly to a user rather
permissions are assigned to a role and
the user will inherit the permissions of
any assigned roles so it makes it easy
for us to create and compose access
policies using roles and permissions and
assign users the necessary permissions
as a by assigning the necessary roles
so with flexible authorization roles are
only used to define a logical grouping
of users
administrators can of course create new
roles as required and rename roles if
the if the if required administrators
assign permissions to roles but we don't
use roles for authorization because if
we do that we won't be independent of
organizational changes and we'll have to
update our code quite often
how does it work under the hood the
engine well it's built entirely using
policy-based authorization and this is
something that really excites me we're
using asp.net core authorization out of
the box to extend the authorization
process we're not writing the security
ourself we're just defining some new
requirements
we can use the custom authorization
authorized attribute to specify required
permissions
and required permissions are then
translated into a policy name so we'll
have a look at that shortly where we're
using the authorized attribute before to
specify a role we'll be using the
authorizer tribute to specify the
required permissions
we will generate these policies
dynamically
using an asp.net core custom policy
provider
so let's have a look at the code
get rid of this
okay let's start here with the
permissions
so you can see with permissions we're
using an enum but we've applied the flag
attribute and that allows us to use and
combine these permissions in very
interesting ways in fact I've got a
dot net interactive notebook that we can
look at to understand that a little bit
better
mm-hmm
Let's Go full screen
full screen there we go
kind of better Okay so we've got a
simple example of some permissions here
you can see that each value is specified
as a power of two starting at 1 through
to 16. we have some interesting values
some interesting Flags we've got none
which is all zeros and we've got all
which is the complement of none all ones
so none would indicate no permissions
whereas all would indicate all
permissions now these are using flags
and you can see that this flag here
indicates the permission of a
and this flag here indicates the
permission of B now we can do some
interesting things with flags if we
wanted to say that the user had
permissions A and C as shown here then
we can simply add them together
so zero zero zero zero one plus zero
zero one zero zero equals zero zero one
zero one or five and so that value of 5
distinctly represents permissions A and
C so using enum Flags we can represent
the user's permissions using a single
number
so let's have a look at some
demonstrations here we've got the user
permissions of a and c and the required
permissions of A and B sorry A or B okay
and so for a user to be authorized based
on the required permissions they need
permission either A or B and in this
case the user has a
let's have a look at what we could do
with flags outputting the permissions as
a string that didn't work
I didn't I've got to run this block
first we'll try again
there we go so if we simply output these
user permissions as a string it provides
us a comma separated value of the
permissions that the user has and the
required required permissions we can
also output their integer values
so five and three
we can check permissions using the
bitwise and operator
so we can see the user permissions are A
and C the required permissions are A and
B and they are authorized
we can add permissions to existing user
permissions using the logical or
operator
so you can see that now the user
permissions are a b
NC
and we can remove permissions using the
logical xor or exclusive or operator
so now the permissions are back to Just
A and C
we need to do something interesting with
these permissions and I think I'll just
show you one of these authorized
attributes let's say on the user's
controller
so
here
we've got authorize and we've specified
the required permissions view users or
manage users
now when ASP comes to evaluate that
access policy
it doesn't actually have an
authorization policy to do that it has
to generate one
so we do that by first creating a policy
name and the policy name is simply
permissions with the value of the
required permissions so the int value
so if we run this now
the required permissions are a and b or
the value 3 and so the policy name that
we will create is called permissions
three
and this provides us with a very easy
out of the box way to utilize asp.net
core policy-based authorization
now here we're just going to update the
required permissions so we can see
creating a different policy name
the permissions are a b and c 7 and the
policy name will be permission seven
so now
we have the capability to create a
policy name but we also need to be able
to later on get the required permissions
based on that policy name
so here we will get the permissions
value from the policy Name by finding
that integer value the policy name is
called permission seven we can pull that
back out and know that that requires
permissions a b or c that's as
complicated as it gets now we get to
just use the asp.net core authorization
capabilities to do the rest
so the first thing that I want to look
at is the application claims Factory
and this is just a little helper
find it hang on try again app claims
principal Factory
so what this will do is add the new
permission claim to the user you saw
that before when we looked at the claims
we had something like permissions 100.
so first it will have find all of the
roles associated with the user then for
each of those roles it will add those
permissions to the user permissions and
then simply add that value as a string
to the claim so if I had permission
seven I would have a claim permissions
7.
very simple little bit of infrastructure
next up we have the flexible
authorization policy provider
and this is responsible for dynamically
creating authorization policies only
when required it's very lazy about it
because we don't really know what
policies will be required we don't
really know what features the user will
try to access so we just create these in
a lazy fashion so there can only be one
authorization policy provider so we
derive the flexible authorization policy
Provider from the default one
you can see that when a policy is
required it calls this get policy async
method now the first thing that we do is
just call the base class and try and get
that policy whatever the name is and if
it exists then we're done
but if it doesn't exist if the policy is
null
and the policy name is a valid
permissions policy name then we have
some work to do
so the first thing we'll do is get the
actual permissions flags from the policy
name so if it's permission seven we'll
take that seven and cast it back into an
enumeration then using the authorization
policy Builder we simply build a policy
based on that now our policy has a
single requirement the permission
authorization requirement and the only
thing we have to pass into it is the
required permissions we already have
that so it's a very simple policy having
done that it's just a matter of adding
the policy specifying the name and the
policy itself next time that same
authorization check needs to occur it
won't be building the policy again
that'll be a one-time thing
okay so let's have a look at this
permission authorization requirement
it's even simpler we simply pass in the
permissions and it stores it in a
property
so how does this authorization
requirement actually get handled well we
have a permission authorization Handler
and this is where we actually look at
the permissions that the user has by
grabbing their permissions claim
converting it back into a permissions
type and then using the bitwise add
operator to determine if there are any
permissions in common and that means
that the user will have at least one of
the required permissions which is fine
now
if that is then successful we're done we
don't need to check anything else and we
will exit and that user will be
authorized and of course if there are
multiple authorized attributes then it
will come back and check against a
second policy for that user so that
means that even with this
permissions-based authorization approach
we can Define very uh we can we can have
well-defined access policies by
organizing the attributes to express the
requirements that we have
next let's have a look at the authorizer
tribute
so this is a special authorized
attribute that is built into the
flexible shared authorization
capabilities
but again it's just extending the
out-of-the-box authorizer tribute and
all it's doing is allowing us to supply
some permissions
now you can see here it doesn't store
the permissions it stores the policy
name and that is a very normal behavior
for the existing authorizer tribute we
can already Supply a policy
you can see that here we can say
employees only well here we're pretty
much doing the same thing but instead of
saying permissions A and C we're saying
permissions three
in a roundabout way we do that by when
setting the policy we will set generate
a policy name given the value of
permissions and when returning it we
will pull the permissions back out of
the policy name
so again this is just driven by ASP net
core policy-based authorization
now if you do have some more procedural
code to write and you'd like to assess
authorization requirements within that
then you use the authorization service
and this is built into asp.net core
authorization and I've simply added an
extension method so that you can assess
your authorization requirements against
the required permissions
using the same approach we take in the
permissions and convert it to a policy
name if that policy doesn't exist
asp.net core will automatically generate
that policy for us and authorize against
those required permissions
all right
so that's quite a lot to cover so we'll
pause there for a moment and take
questions yes
three and four yeah
yes
yeah
yeah of course well that some of those
values that you specified aren't powers
of two
so they represent combinations of flags
rather than individual flags and so when
you look at the permissions here they're
all powers of two so three and four well
three is actually a and b and 4 is
actually C so three and four uh comes to
seven so that's one plus two plus four
so that's a b and c
no problem yes
in this case yeah
so in in this scenario in this in this
specific one so the enumeration is
backed by an INT so 32 maximum values
excluding none and all all is really
useful
um actually I I'll I'll just show you
one thing that I really love about all
and then we'll come back to the maximum
value
so if we go to the DB initializer we'll
try no that's in another project
DB initializer
when I initialize the administrator's
role they always get assigned
permissions all and it's so easy to do
that so when we add a new permission
they automatically have it if we update
the permissions they automatically have
it so yes the permissions that I'm
currently using are restricted to 32
permissions if I change it to long it'll
be restricted to 64 permissions 64 is
pretty good but it's not going to work
for every solution so at that point we
have to decide what we want to do next
so we could start storing permissions in
the database alongside the roles and
they could have an identity against each
individual permission obviously we're
not going to then be able to store the
um the permissions in such a nice way
using a single value will have multiple
claims representing the permissions that
are available or we could have something
like comma separated values representing
the permissions that are available so
we'll have to take a different approach
but the result will be the same roles
and permissions will be stored using
claims and they will be assessed using
Dynamic authorization policies in
asp.net core
any other questions
no problem let's continue
I'd like to provide one final
demonstration add in a new permission
this would be typically completed by
developers when they're building new
requirements
the auditor currently does not have
access to the access control page and
they would like to see who has access to
what so let's give that a try
so the first thing that we'll need to do
is
update the permissions
not that one
this one
so we have
the next value to be view Access Control
128.
okay
we'll stop that
so now we need to apply the policy for
view Access Control where it's necessary
let's start on the client again
so
make that a bit smaller
so we'll go over here
to oh I'll use the sorry I'll use the
shortcuts a little bit easier to find
things when I don't have a mouse nav
menu
okay so access control is down the
bottom here
and currently only users with
permissions configure Access Control
so we'll say
configure or view Access Control
all right
next up we need to change the access
control page itself
so I think that's at Access Control
index
good
and we can see here the only real place
that can make a change is the import so
let's use the authorize View
now I can't use the out of the box
authorized view so I created an
extension on that flexible authorized
View
and will say that the authorized users
must have
hopefully let's clean this up a little
bit
we'll say authorized and not authorized
okay now I really wanted to find some
permissions here
not coming up
let's find out why
flexible authorized View
whoops I'm making a big mess I gotta
stop
okay making it worse all right trying
again flexible
authorized for you
so the flexible authorized view has the
parameter permissions
which is interesting it's not coming up
for me
so uh
let's just exploded
so let's
go back here
and
I will
just put that in clipboard save the
changes do a quick build
see if we get oh that's not going to
build
see if we get a better result
thanks Brendan I'm glad you're here
today
that's awesome
permissions Dot
so ah no
well no yeah you're right you're right
that is right permissions dot uh
configure Access Control
there we go
so that's nice and easy to use
and then we can say if you can configure
Access Control
then you get the standard check box
and if you're not authorized we'll just
do a quick and dirty and we'll say you
can't change it
and once more it's disabled
okay
one last change to make we have to
protect authorization on the back end so
let's load up
the
access control controller
you'll probably just call that the
Access Controller
it would would be fine
there we go so currently the entire uh
controller is restricted to configure
Access Control
so we'll take that
away
and we've got two actions in here one to
get the configuration so that'll be our
view access control or depending on how
we Define our permissions it might be
view or configure
but our administrators have all so we'll
just go View
and then over here
for update configuration of course
configure Access Control
so we'll go ahead and run that now and
see if it's working as expected for the
auditor can they view Access Control do
they have read-only access
wait for it to start up
looking good a bit of a mess here
that's not good
all right again
okay hang on a sec
this is flexible off
so it must be running on a different
port and that's the old basic auth one
here we go
now logging in
auditor
I knew that has happened I've got to
learn to copy and paste more
okay we can't see Access Control
so that's no good
I'm just gonna
of course I forgot to assign order to
the permission
that's let's leave that there so I don't
have to type in the password more than I
have to
and go to incognito
logging in
admin
whoops
I mean I'm gonna have to bring a whole
desk next time I'll bring a desk an
extra monitor a keyboard a mouse
and my headset
we'll be right at home
okay here we are we can see everything
scrolling down we've got view access
control so we'll grant that to our
auditors
we can come over here and do a quick
refresh
they've got Access Control
and they're not authorized to access the
resource we can fix that too
so let's go to access control
index now of course I'm trying to
demonstrate how easy the flexible
authorization approach is so don't take
this part as an example
so we'll go to the top here
and change
that to configure or view Access Control
try again there we go
now
hot reload doesn't tend to work very
well for me
so we'll just run it again
sometimes it's working really nicely I
have the best results when I go dot net
watch run rather through Visual Studio
which is very nice
that's the administrator
and that's the auditor so now you can
see they have access to access control
they can't change anything and so
there's our documentation right
we can see who has access to what when
developers create new features they
Define the necessary access policies
using permissions rather than roles
okay
so in summary
today we looked at authorization with
ASP net core I demonstrated the typical
approach using role-based access control
and you saw that for a simple
requirement such as adding an auditor
role it was a lot of work we had to
develop test deploy and document changes
which of course we forgot to do
I then showed a flexible approach using
permissions-based authorization and with
this approach it was trivial to add a
new auditor role
now for small applications with a small
amount of users the standard approach is
probably fine if you just have one or
two roles say administrators and users
then the flexible approach could be
Overkill
but for production applications in large
Enterprise typically a flexible approach
will be essential it's the only thing
that will isolate you from those
organization changes and help you
deliver to deliver business value rather
than making changes to support that sort
of thing
and this is going to result in putting
the power into the hands of the
application users and administrators
rather than the Developers
so you can find the code and slides on
GitHub if you're Keen to learn more
so that's at github.com
jasontaylorduff flexible asp.net core
authorization
as promised here's the QR code for the
ssw rewards app you can scan that code
earn some points and win some prizes
I hope you've enjoyed my talk today
it's great to see so many of you in
person
thank you
[Applause]
we've got plenty of time for questions
if anyone has any more
yes
yeah no problem so when you're loading
the permissions dynamically I think that
the best approach is to have a c-sharp
file representing the identification and
the name of those permissions as
constants that will give you some nice
flexibility to apply those permissions
in the same way but then you'll need an
additional process to sync those
permissions to the database okay and I
like to do that when when the
application is initialized and basically
what it will do is go and make sure all
of those permissions are in the database
and if not it will go and create them
and of course the permissions
enumeration I showed is quite simple I
would also want to add some attributes
to that so that we can have a
description so that we can have a
display name those sorts of things but I
wanted to focus on the engine behind the
scenes so that you could see how to
implement it
any other questions
can you can you say that again sorry
contact the method with the authorized
actually what you did
in the back end can you can you tag the
method with the authorized attribute
that that's the thing that ideally
unless you're going to specify the
permission name or identifier by hand I
think it's best to have some some kind
of C sharp compiled object to represent
those permissions so if you need to have
them in the database by all means do
that but sync it based off that C sharp
class keep it synced based off that C
sharp class now that gives you the
advantage of being able to query and
join and easily associate additional
information while also being able to use
those authorized attributes
any other questions
yes
implementation decide to switch how
hard oh well you've you let's have a
look at the card
so it is all contained
in this particular project within the
shared project
in a single folder
called authorization
so essentially your changes will be
limited to this set of files and to any
authorized attributes that you've
applied or anywhere where you have used
those permissions so the impact of the
change will be fairly limited but it
will cost depend on how many access
policies you've actually applied the
nice thing is is that when you move from
permissions enumeration to something
else it'll be breaking changes and
you'll see those in the output and
you'll be able to fix them one at a time
so not too bad of course if you went to
something like a static class with
constants then it's almost the same
you'll be replacing those little or
operators uh but yeah otherwise not too
difficult
yes
at all yeah that's right
that income I didn't think about
operator overloading well that is cool
yeah
that's right if you make it behave
exactly the same as Nina
no changes
and it's still very descriptive a little
bit more descriptive than when you say
authorized roles we have to know that
it's all when we read the permissions
value we know that it's all because it's
using the or operator so permissions a
or permissions B rather than
administrators comma accounts
it's going to be easy I think to just
put an array of
it'll be easier to what sorry
yeah and you could think about having
multiple arrays of bit Flags
yes it gets a bit more difficult to
manage because in the back end we're
creating a policy name so we'd have to
think about the max length of that
policy name and if we have multiple
arrays of bit flags and we're saying uh
that the permissions can come from any
of those enumerations it's just a bit
tricky I think we can do it but yeah
okay yeah well hopefully soon we'll get
128 bit
and then then we'll have 128 options to
play with
Maybe
all right thanks again everyone I'll be
around all day so feel free to come off
and chat and we can look at the code and
and talk options
see ya
thank you
[Applause]